U.S President Joe Biden is set to meet
the Prime Minister and President of
Vietnam in the coming hours it's part of
the schedule for the final day of his
trip to the country the trip to Hanoi
comes as Washington tries to strengthen
ties in Southeast Asia amid souring
relations between the U.S and China
Jessica Washington joins us now live
from Hanoi and so Jessica despite what
President Biden has to say is the
lasting impression he leaves behind as
his visit winds up that this is about
containing China
well send me just a short while ago we
saw President Biden making his way to
Vietnam's presidential Palace on the way
to meet a Vietnam's prime minister and
then later the president important to
note that he's meeting all facets of
Vietnam's leadership which certainly
signifies the the importance that
Washington is placing on this bilateral
relationship with Vietnam what we've
heard repeatedly from President Biden is
that this bolstering of ties with
Vietnam or other countries around the
region is not intended to contain China
but rather to create a stable and
peaceful indo-pacific and that he has no
intention of hurting or causing any
damage to China now it is worth noting
and seeing this in the broader context
of the U.S engagement with southeast
Asia throughout the Biden Administration
Washington attempting to portray itself
as a stable steady and reliable partner
one that's not only engaging with the
region because its relations with China
have taken around the sour turn but but
that is certainly part of the equation
and a large part of the reason why
Washington is placing such importance on
this relationship with Vietnam worth
noting that as Washington is looking to
diversify Supply chains out of China
will Vietnam's status as an emerging
manufacturing Hub is certainly
significant here
and if we look at things from the
Vietnamese perspective what are they
looking for in this kind of upgrading of
relations Is it just about business or
also something of a rebalancing Act of
their international relations
well there's certainly much for Vietnam
to gain here uh certainly a an attempt
to show balance in its foreign policy
worth noting that as Washington has
achieved this upgraded bilateral tie
they're now on the same level as Beijing
and Moscow in terms of the economic
situation or this bolstering of ties
with the US has certainly been
beneficial for Vietnam the trade surplus
has been beneficial in terms of economic
growth and job creation some of the
deals that have been arranged throughout
this week of diplomacy certainly
significant for the Vietnamese economy
I'll just make a note of some of them
Microsoft will work with to develop
generative AI products for Vietnam and
other Emerging Markets Nvidia will work
with several Vietnamese firms on AI
there's also an investment and
Innovation Summit taking place today on
Monday in Hanoi representatives from U.S
tech firms meeting with other firms in
Vietnam including Vietnam's evap value
manufacturer Vin far so certain only
some significant economic opportunities
for Vietnam here in pursuing closer ties
with Washington while also maintaining
that Balancing Act of ensuring positive
ties with Beijing as well
all right Jessica Washington there